a oi na melhor e até 9 anos e hoje vem
falar sobre uma ferramenta simples e
fácil que pode mudar um pode perceber
melhor ferramenta
depois de várias e várias conversas que
tive com minha avó minha vó ajudava uma
comunidade chamada saiam nessa
comunidade onde ela fez o censo vocês é
quando você passa por várias casas e
pode perceber o estilo de vida das
pessoas hoje em dia minha voz de uma
criança que melhor pode perceber que
quando ela dessa simples e fácil
ferramenta se transforma também
percebemos que as pessoas vão fazer a
diferença quando as deixar entrevistas e
começar a ter compaixão mas para isso
elas precisam ser chamadas a seguir terá
eventos o que causa maior é a falta dele
na sociedade sem amor no nível sócio
econômico cultural pais muitas vezes as
pessoas não se sentem merecedoras
acredita que nunca recebeu nada de bom
da vida não conseguem dar amor pois
sabemos que temos e muitas vezes não
consegue desenvolver a capacidade de ter
compaixão para ninguém nunca morei aqui
o mais pra vocês uma frase de madre
teresa de calcutá que ela fala que a
falta de amor a pior de todas as presas
isso é uma triste realidade sem amor no
nível sócio econômico e cultural alto
muitas vezes pais trocam amor pelos
presentes
as pessoas passam a achar que o amor é
comprado se tornam pessoas egoístas
fazem bullying pois não conhece os
limites e acho que dinheiro pode comprar
tudo o que eu mostro para vocês uma
frase antonilton que ele fala que é amor
demais nunca esperava criança mas
queremos estar animados quando
substituímos a presença pelo por
presentes com esses exemplos nas uma
sociedade agressiva e egoísta
as guerras começam o número de corrupção
isso cresce o número de crianças
abandonadas aumentam e nossas estradas
ficam sem esperança
já o efeito benéfico do amor universal
são lhe é dono da auto estima cura todas
as dores e principalmente nos liberta
onde há amor não agressão nem a falta de
compreensão
antes de passar um vídeo pra vocês
gostei é de falar que não é só os
humanos que fizemos de amor mas também
os animais
[Música]
o boi é grande peixe é t
[Aplausos]
[Música]
antes de finalizar a apresentação
gostaria de falar uma oração no silêncio
desse dia que amanhece ele pedir a paz
a sabedoria ea força eu quero olhar o
mundo com os olhos cheios de amor é
paciente compreensiva mãe se prudente
ver além das aparências seus filhos como
tu mesmo ver e assim saber bem quem cada
um
ana soul vida toda a catalunha guarda
minha língua de toda a maldade que só de
bênção se enche meu espírito que eu seja
tão bondosa alegre que todo chegar e me
sinto sua presença revés time de tanta
beleza senhor empregou decidir tiver a
todos
agora eu gostaria de agradecer à minha
avó por ter me ajudado a fazer esse
projeto e pela sua atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]